vos mensurations ses 87 59 90
presque alors ya quand même une mauvaise
nouvelle c'est que vous étiez dans le
guinness book des records pour vos
jambes qui mesurent à mettre 24 je le
dis à toutes les femmes qui mesure
chaque 24
et elle s'est seulement ses jambes oui
bon
tous les mecs qui mesure avec 24 ce qui
veut dire notre
saison pour à jean-louis
nouvelle c'est que quelqu'un de nouveau
est arrivé avec un nouveau record
km 76 y en avait toujours quelqu'un sais
tu mates le roi cobra tu sais tu
n'achètes grande vous êtes slovaque et
la fillette chèque est toujours une
rivalité entre les coûts et les
slovaques non c'est pas vrai laurette
s'appelle marcel aster clova et ses
jambes font un maître 29 donc l ad
gentes dames je sais que je devrai
nouvelle pour toutes les femmes qui nous
sommes qui mesurent medvedev c'est une
bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle absolument
alors vous
vous marrez des mecs là à temps adriana
vient de slovaquie ok bien vous allez me
dire quelle est la capitale de la
slovaquie alors la capitale de la
slovaquie je veux dire si j'osais si on
le dit aux slovaques ses proches et
quelques non non je sais pas des halles
la capitale de la slovaquie alors moi
vers l'est je suis pas douée personnes
tuées sur qui cite personne le sait
niche hollande nos missions
oui oui comment les gens connaissent mal
les pays de l'est
c'est très complexe non non ça c'est le
nom du village où elle habite voilà non
je ne sais pas mais personne ne sait je
sais même pas si je l'aurais su modère
ses pratice là bas
ben non je connais alors quelle est la
langue qui est parlée en slovaquie l'âge
le slovène non le slovène passée en
slovénie le slovène je sais pas chanter
en choeur en slovaquie quelle est la
langue qui est parlée en slovaquie
j'étais mauvais là dessus
m
oui
donc on va faire un petit replay parce
que c'est un grand mot avant c'est pas
mal c'est télévision petit replay serge
s'il vous plaît je vais voir ma femme tu
es là
non je suis pas marion non mais j'avais
une copine à man
on va voir cad on va voir si vous gagnez
un deuxième baiser d'adriana karembeu
quelle est la monnaie
utilisée
quelle est la monnaie utilisée en
slovaquie
la monnaie les revenus
c'est l'oncle du directeur c'est normal
c'est non je ne sais pas quand mr k
c'est la couronne slovaque couronne
slovaque
bon notre question donc bien une autre
question oui la population de la
slovaquie ils sont combien c'est à dire
ils sont 5 millions cette année y en a
le taux de chômage en slovaquie 5
millions pour cent a pas mal combien si
c'est vrai ça et c'est ce que j'ai 18
par la main tendue c'est madame un bisou
serrage de mains
alors peut-être que vous pouvez gagner
un deuxième
deuxième baiser ou un troisième pour
certains mais bon là c'est la tête
quel est le quel est le taux d'inflation
on joue pour liane ou pour jouer pour la
fille que vous voulez de la station qui
a le taux d'inflation de la slovaquie
j'irai 10 des choix non plus que c'est
la teinte pour quatre vingt mois sept et
demi ce saint curé pierre si pendant six
ans avant cette épreuve c'est la femme
lou directeur qui a trouvé décidément et
j'ai gardé contre cette chaîne va vivre
normalement et dans la famille c'est
l'étranger est bien connaître le taux
d'inflation de la slovaquie avec moi
c'est vicieux s'il fait de ce soir vous
étudiez vous lisiez le quid c'est bien
c'est bien quelle est la couleur des
cheveux d'andriana bon
ou pas bon ça va alors tiens une
question comme ça et ce qu eva herzigova
et et tchécoslovaques soient vagues
slovaque tchèque eva herzigova cha cha
cha cha cha bravi oui bien sûr tchèque
bisous
éloignez les enfants des postes de
télévision
par tous dans une heure
j'aurais dû dire j'aimais beaucoup son
mari aux armes à venir comme toute
évidence non non non c'est déjà
rencontré c'est un homme charmant
rencontrer
on sait on fait des bonnes choses mais
non mais c'est vrai quand aux mesures un
peu plus km 24
janvier 75 au
revoir
bientôt sympathie lors adriana vous avez
besoin de femmes une fille c'est
exceptionnel en dehors de notre physique
disant vous a vécu deux contes de fées
dans votre vie c'est à dire d'habitude
les gens ont un seul conte de fées dans
leur vie adrian a eu deux contes de fées
premier conte de fées elle habite dans
un petit village qui s'appelle
isabelle brès non bref notre village qui
est perdu dans la forêt tu as tu
imagines salle village perdu dans la
forêt à 12 heures de train de prague un
petit tortillard terrible et glacial
intelligence un petit tortillard
terrible et glaciale où il faut pas
s'endormir ce comme vous sous peine de
se faire voler ses bagages vous
souhaitez vous craignez plus tôt les
militaires elle sait se faire voler ses
bagages et la famille votre votre
famille était très pauvre
patron
vous sauviez un petit chewing gum à la
fraise c'était un beau cadeau ou si tu
veux
donc vous allez à la faculté à prague
c'est l'époque de la révolution de
velours
oui c'était la première
je suis rentré en vérité ce métier ma
faculté ce métier
89 c'est toute l'année de la révolution
de velours c'est vrai on était dans la
rue oui c'est vrai et là enfin quelques
années après trois ans après en 1992
vous être marquée par un talent de ce
côté vous gagnez dans un pays où il
avait pas de magazines féminins c'est à
dire tout le monde est habillé en
uniforme des uniformes fabriqués dans
des usines et donc votre encontre quoi
elle gagné un concours le pays énervé
billets d'avion pour l'appareil
et voilà premier conte de fées et le
départ était tellement précipitée que
son père objet de donner l'argent de
poche je n'ai pas osé le dire
pas l'argent ni par les français ni
anglais rien de toi je connaissais rien
son boulot je ne connaissais pas la
structure du métier je savais pas
comment ça marche et quand d'être match
j'étais vraiment perdu un petit peu
finalement j'ai trouvé que j'étais
contente j'étais content d'être à paris
je suis allé tout de suite vers l'arc de
triomphe la tour eiffel
la tour est finalement prêté une
aventure j'étais fasciné y avait la tour
eiffel et l'arc de triomphe mais vous
étiez fasciné par les magasins de
nourriture la première fois que cette
rentrée dans une clé crémerie vous avez
pleuré j'avais tellement de ya tellement
d amour
je me suis
j'ai acheté tous ses yaourts coûté la
vie à une espèce de petit dessin holiday
et puis j'ai découpé les des stages d
est collée sur le mur dans ma petite
chambre c'est mignon c'est très beau
mais c'est une très belle histoire 52,3
on est très émus ou alors berry et miou
voilà l'été en boule alors vous êtes
embauché par elite c'est assez
rapidement
vous aviez alors votre petite amie de
shia qu'il était trop vague par dont il
était resté là bas lui les boules il ya
des raisons physiques méfier mais ce n
est jamais revenue
mais là ce soir
yes venir
alimi
je fais bien le fait bien le sera car
ils oublient stomach
parce que
c'est pas vrai bon jack et ses soucis
alors voilà c'est comme ça qu adriana
karembeu se retrouve aux bahamas a à a
gagné en une journée ce que
c'est plus d'une journée ce que disent
que des gens là-bas gagner en plusieurs
mois et voilà c'est le premier conte de
fées ok on passe au deuxième point de me
fais
comment est ce que vous connaissez tous
je voudrais me ding a newspaper that you
all games et en deuxième conte de fées
en suis là tout le monde le connaît 1
dans un bus d'aéroport voit la super
connu ou connaissent et dans un bus
d'aéroport
connaissez pas le tombe sur un type qui
me dit je pêche moins intelligent la
question vous mesurer combien jack voilà
comment draguer adriana karembeu je veux
eh ben vous vous saviez même pas qu'il
était honteux saviez pas que c'était un
grand grand joueur de foot lui pensait
j'ai aucune chance il se dit tu vois
évidemment je me change tout le monde
pendant 100 ans vous voyant et vous vous
direz vous vous dites quand les hommes
me voient ils pensent toujours j'ai
aucune chance et voilà ça marchera
jamais alors que c'est pas vrai alors
ils sont consommés possible
les autres bien sûr la soirée
les imprimés bien sûr non mais mais mais
son mari et à ses jeunes donc c'est un
très bel homme oui mais il faut le dire
parce que je dis bon tous les deux alors
c'est fou ouais le couple étincelant
parce qu'on ne regarde plus personne
d'autre mais je veux dire quand ils
arrivent mais lui il fait vraiment un
très bel homme donc il est dit j'ai pas
ma chance j'y crois pas trop à qui sait
quand même que josé bové si vous si vous
rencontriez adriana karembeu dans un bus
d'aéroport vous lui diriez quoi pour la
branche est est ce que vous lui diriez
comme question
du bien de quoi josé sérieux
que vous me il faut que je dise pareil
en fait oui combien vous mesurer combien
c'est trop tard
autre chose voilà et donc alors après
bon ils montent dans l'avion tous les
deux elle avoue d'habitude fait semblant
de dormir quand vous êtes dans un avion
là vous gardez un oeil ouvert
il se met à côté d'elle et puis voilà
bien la fin du voyage il vous a laissé
son chapeau ça c'est un truc à savoir
avec adriana karembeu faut laisser son
chapeau celle là beaucoup ça vous a
touché oui parce que qu'est-ce que je
peux faire qu'est ce que j'ai fait avec
un chapeau c'était un peu
c'était mignon parce qu'elle me disait
j'ai rien j'ai rien sur moi elle n'avait
pas même pas même pas le valais rien
alors je m'adonnais voilà et alors vous
lui donnez votre numéro de téléphone
quand même assez rapidement la première
fois vous avez donné c'est vrai
normalement je fais pas ça oui j'espère
bien alors deux jours plus tard il vous
appelle et
vous l'inviter à prendre un café mais
comme vous êtes à milan et lui a parlé
de moi qui prends un avion là c'est déjà
plus déjà plus fort l'a dit terminant
t'en fais pas j'arrive
assez fort il a gagné et un an après
dans un restaurant fin du deuxième conte
de fées un an après dans le restaurant
il prend votre main comme ça sous la
table il enlève votre vieille bague et
se caressant une bague gens
vous vous êtes fait voler la bague de
votre maman et de notre papa tenons il
lui dit tu veux tu être ma femme tu
admets que des trucs simples combien
vous mesurez est ce que tu vas être ma
femme je veux mon chapeau tu ferais mon
chapeau nous on se fatigue
je fais de la télé
pas du tout alors la faute de notre
vous fournir la fin du deuxième conte de
fées voilà parce que vous disiez ce
qu'ils font un couple formidable wi fi
sont un symbole en plus c'est ça qui est
formidable c'est un sens et puis c'est
vraiment un couple qui fait et si vous
me permettez c'est un couple qui fait
rêver les gens parce que d'un côté il ya
pas plus populaire dans tous les pays du
monde qu'un top model au jour
d'aujourd'hui et qu'un sportif soit
parce que ce sont les gens les plus
populaires au monde plus populaire que
les acteurs que le cinéma que les
chanteurs que ne trouve à toutes les
personnalités que les animateurs télé
que les journalistes vient donc non mais
je sais je sais je sais j'y jouais dans
l'ombre extraordinairement un donc
sportif grands sportifs en plus et puis
une très très belle à leur top model
donc ces six formidable ça leur adriana
comme vous parlait pas très bien le
français
je vous faire une interview très simple
c'est une interview à laquelle vous
devez répondre uniquement par oui ou par
non et c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle
l'interview oui non jingle
[Musique]
yoo move
j'avais couché turbo entendu yoomove de
diogène de jalousie pendant le jingle il
faut pas vous allez mannequin c'est
limite un
bon ballon à faire serge en le refermant
allume un
tout nouveau tout beau lotto
bouge pas
je roule roule sur des chemins je fais
pas
[Musique]
on
we know it ski op ok sur you just vous
répondez seulement par oui ou non
est ce que ça vous gêne de gagner autant
d'argent
non
est-ce que vous en donnez à vos parents
oui
est-ce que vous en donner aux gens
qu'ils mendient dans la rue oui est ce
que le luxe vous a rendu plus
capricieuse
est ce que si demain vous rencontriez
dans un avion dans un no d'un homme dont
vous êtes folle est-ce que vous
quitteriez tout pour le grand amour
non parce que j'ai déjà
mais un autre nom
un autre mais éventuellement également
un types habillés en noir
la côte est
est ce que vous avez déjà fouiller dans
les poches de christian
alain jamet
si un jour ça peut arriver est ce que si
vous le trompiez vous lui diriez
elle lui dira pas le jeu c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon c'est moi parce qu'on a
beaucoup de pièces je veux déjà est ce
que vous avez réalisé tous vos fantasmes
non non non non
pas possible
si christian un jour il rentre à la
maison à madrid et vous trouveriez avec
une autre fille est-ce que vous aurez
est ce que vous auriez honte
vous pensez à la scène là oui moi aussi
remonté tout le monde prend sa veste
elle se moque
[Applaudissements]
bien des bureaux il ya des blancs qui en
disent long dont la main
vous auriez rente qui vous trouve le lit
avec une autre fille un peu oui
si un jour vous découvrez que christian
karembeu est homosexuel est ce que vous
restez avec lui quand même oui ah oui
bon c'est vrai amour bien l'air et
dernière question
quand vous aimez quelqu'un quand vous
aimez vraiment quelqu'un est ce que vous
pouvez tout faire avec cette personne et
ras la même pas attendu la fin de
l'arrêt pour travaux
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu